[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio moro
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en parís un programa semanal de
radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
donde damos la palabra a políticos
artistas personas del mundo de las
ciencias las artes y de la sociedad
civil los franceses están convocados a
las urnas el 10 y el 24 de abril para
elegir al presidente o presidenta de la
república que les gobernarán los
próximos cinco años 12 candidatos 44
mujeres perdón y ocho hombres pretenden
obtener el voto favorable de los
electores uno de ellos el actual
presidente de la república y manuel
macrón aparece como favorito de las
encuestas para obtener un segundo
mandato por este motivo y para hacer el
balance social de su gobierno hemos
invitado aquí en nuestros estudios hayan
vidal miembro de la organización attac
la asociación por la imposición de las
transacciones financieras y por la
acción ciudadana que acaba de publicar
un libro que lleva por título macro
hagamos el balance una obra colectiva
que critica en todos los frentes la
política del actual mandatario enmanuel
macrón y abidal bienvenido a este escala
en parís
muchas gracias por recibirme gracias por
acompañarnos cómo surgió la idea de este
libro colectivo en el que participan 24
autores pero que digo yo es
completamente contra el gobierno del
presidente manuel macro para nosotros en
nuestra organización
siempre tuvimos
sospechas con el candidato macro ya en
2017 un candidato que se decía ni de
izquierda ni de derecha un candidato que
se decía al mismo tiempo para bajar los
impuestos y para tener políticas
sociales y nosotros no pero no para
decía difícilmente realizable como meta
enseguida fue confirmado que al final
terminó siendo el candidato de los ricos
y que subieron las
cualidades las desigualdades en el país
que hicimos un primer balance ya un año
después y nos pudimos ahí resaltar que
las políticas que llevaba el presidente
no eran tanto con un requisito de
pragmatismo como lo suele decir mucho
pero más bien ideológicas
y ahora que se acerca el final de
mociones no el fin de su mandato de las
elecciones y con todas las crisis que
hubieron del comida ahora la grasa
nos asustamos que no se hable tanto de
su balance entonces para nosotros era
importante volver sobre todo ese balance
ustedes califican en los primeros cinco
años como un periodo perdido y sobre
todo acusan al presidente emmanuel
macrón de ese el presidente de los ricos
como justifica esta acusación
estamos en un bueno en tiempos de
urgencia social y ecológicas grandes y
no se hicieron pasos adelante si al
contrario se hicieron pasos atrás
por ejemplo
desde el primer año de los primeros años
los impuestos sobre las grandes riquezas
bajaron fue suprimido el impuesto de
solidaridad sobre las fortunas y también
se hicieron una reforma de la flat tax
sobre
las los bienes financiar josh que
costaron mucho dinero porque es dinero
que no llega al estado y para
contrabalancear eso por ejemplo se bajó
las reformas las ayudas para la locación
de apartamentos para la gente más
humilde entonces ahí ya tenemos un
ejemplo en los primeros años de un
balance de cómo se ayuda de una parte a
la gente con más presupuestos y como ese
dinero que no se les saca a la gente con
más riqueza se les saca en ayuda a la
gente más pobre de acuerdo hablemos de
lo que es un triángulo fundamental de la
administración del presidente manuel
macro el empleo el desempleo y la
pobreza hay que recordar que al inicio
de su mandato del presidente manuel
macro no impulsó una serie de reformas
de carácter laboral notablemente y en
términos del seguro del desempleo el
objetivo según el propio gobierno es
promover la creación de empleo y sobre
todo incentivar que la gente
precisamente se incorpore a esos mundo
laboral ustedes critican esas reformas
las acusan de liberales pero al final de
cuentas no se puede negar que entre el
2017 y ahora se ha creado un millón de
empleos
bueno ahí hay varias cosas que decir no
y que contar y que analizar la primera
es que ya había una tendencia desde 2015
a la creación de empleos que no tanto
viene de reformas pero de una situación
económico que se mejoraba
además de eso lo que podemos ver es que
todas las reformas unas laborales pero
también fiscales los impuestos de las
sociedades de las grandes empresas que
se bajan también las cotizaciones
sociales que fueron bajadas y que
representan un presupuesto grande todas
esas reformas sobre 5 años son 150 de
billones de euros 150 millones exacto y
se ve que no lo decimos sólo nosotros lo
dicen organismos públicos como francia
estrategia que depende del del primer
ministro que no son esas imbert no esas
reformas no son a orígenes de creación
de empleos o de inversiones de manera
notable que decir que gastamos mucho
dinero sin poco ventajas para el empleo
al final de cuentas al contrario se veo
que había un reporte de esa subida en
los dividendos de los
de los más ricos que tenían acciones en
las empresas y todo eso y más allá de
eso se nota que la creación de empleo
que hay también es muy precaria
de manera absoluta es más o menos lo
mismo pero de manera relativa abajo y la
creación de nuevos empleos son empleos
por ejemplo hay muchos de la creación de
empleo creo estos últimos años fueron de
de contratos de corta y lo sienten
duración que son de unos tres meses más
o menos en promedio sobre la creación de
más de 50% que es una lógica
generalmente que se han puesto en toda
europa pero yo quisiera volver sobre un
tema tan vital uno de los elementos más
críticos o de los momentos más críticos
durante el primer mandato del presidente
manuel macro fue el surgimiento del
movimiento los llamados chalecos
amarillos recordemos que fue a finales
del 2018 donde miles de habitantes de
francia de las zonas periurbanas
notablemente salieron a protestar entre
finales del 2018 y hasta el primer
trimestre la primera mitad del 2019 el
argumento la causa que generó esto
evidentemente hay una ruptura eso no se
puede negar en el aumento del precio de
la gasolina del combustible pero también
es verdad que el gobierno finalmente
después de esas protestas logró absorber
esa protesta y fue a partir de ahí donde
hubo un cambio de la parte del gobierno
de manuel macro a partir de ese
movimiento el momento y hasta ahora el
gobierno decidió simplemente reducir en
cinco mil millones de euros los
impuestos a el sector menos acomodados
de la sociedad esto quiere decir que el
gobierno ha respondido de alguna manera
a este tipo de protestas me equivoco
bueno para empezar no no sé si tanto se
absorbió la crisis de los chalecos
amarillos que se reprimió tenemos que
recordar que el movimiento nunca hubo
una represión tan grande estos 20
últimos años que en el que hubo con el
movimiento de los chalecos amarillos es
verdad que se dice que fue la represión
más grandes del final de la guerra de
argelia exacto más de 11.000 de
retenidos en custodia creación de nuevas
infracciones previas durante los eventos
más de mil heridos a graves pérdidas de
ojos pérdidas en la mano pero choques en
la mano se vio de nuevo policías de
motocicletas que había estado prohibido
después de la muerte de malick use king
y todo eso hizo que el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos cede se deja todo
claro pero está la parte política por la
parte económica los cinco mil millones
de euros que el gobierno concedió en
reducción de impuestos como la juzgan
ustedes
si el problema no es tanto que nosotros
vemos que que esas reducciones subieron
acaso
para los más humildes o lo que
criticamos obviamente es que esa
reducción tenga incidencia sobre los más
ricos que tendrían que apoyar ahora se
está subiendo mucho la gasolina por
ejemplo de nuevo viene esa problemática
que son en realidad
impuestos que son los menos justos de
todos y amido rápidamente porque el
tiempo evoluciona muy pronto una de las
frases favoritas del presidente manuel
macro no ha sido justamente se le
buscaba al mismo tiempo una frase que lo
utilizo mucho con motivo de la crisis de
lakovic 2021 el gobierno creo yo que
globalmente ha invertido 25 puntos más
del producto interno bruto para combatir
esta crisis de la pandemia como todos
los gobiernos globalmente piensa usted
que al final de cuentas ha salido más o
menos partido cierto éxito visto los
resultados que la economía hay cierto
cayó como nuestro resto de las economías
pero que ha logrado recuperarse muy
rápidamente que balance si usted está
política del mismo tiempo en el caso de
la comida
bueno no no podemos criticar el hecho
que obviamente se sostuvo el empleo
y al mismo tiempo las ayudas no eso lo
vemos obviamente de manera positiva
ahora el problema es que muchas veces
esas ayudas no tienen
contrapeso fueron de manera
abiertas y shin shin
requisitos en contra perdón como un
repartido entre partidas
y eso no nos hace la pregunta de poco
importa el precio porque era el gran
gran es lo que denuncia pues te lo que
cueste cueste lo que cuesta de macrón el
problema es que nos va a costar cuánto
nos va a costar y quién va a pagar eso
vamos a ver ahora lo que viene si hace
nuevo mandato cuál lo van a hacer las
políticas quién van a tener que pagar
por ahora se ve que los que pagaron no
fueron los más ricos pero muchas veces
la clase media la gente más humilde y
bueno también se puede criticar que esas
ayudas durante el gobi hay todas partes
de la población que no la recibieron y
que fueron un poco
como decir de metida de lado una última
pregunta por una respuesta rápida pero
al final de cuentas ustedes decíamos son
muy críticos con respecto del primer
mandato del presidente manuel macro como
explicando ustedes que aparezca con
claro favorito para ganar las elecciones
el próximo 10 al 24 de abril e incluso
con 10 puntos por arriba de su
contrincante más cercano de manera muy
breve y al final bueno lo de manera
breve lo veo muy complicado de resumirlo
de hecho además no creo que es un
trabajo de politólogo
creo que ayudó también como es decir en
las crisis las varias crisis la crisis
de kobe de la que la crisis ahora la
guerra de ucrania hace que la gente
también una parte tiene ganas de
estabilidad es y se ven en las últimas
encuestas cuando empezó la guerra de
ucrania estaba a 30 ahora ya está un
poco bajando bueno además de eso
polaris son mucho la sociedad manuel
macro no encontrando
chivos expiatorios
y acusando a la gente que no tenía los
marginales otros y bueno y cristalizó de
manera muy fuerte su
su base electoral de hecho se puede
decir rápidamente que el otro problema
es el que la gente ya no tiene más
confianza en la política mucha gente y
mucha gente no votar y cada vez menos
pues estamos llegando ya al final de
este escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle high and bead al miembro de
la asociación attac que ha publicado el
libro macrón hagamos el balance su
presencia en nuestros estudios muchas
gracias ya muchas gracias ustedes a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita la
próxima semana aquí en otra escala en
parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]